Speaker 1: Let's go now from steve doocy
to harris faulkner. Harris faulkner has
become an interesting character on fox news.
Harris faulkner has become one of the greatest
trump brown noses and defenders on Fox News.
And that's why it's particularly interesting
that her review of Trump's speech Tuesday
night at Mar a Lago was not exactly glowing.
Now she does sort of try. By the way,
this is not an image of Harris Faulkner.
This is this is a this is a guy, Harris
Faulkner. As a black woman. And this is
this. There's a man here. You'll see her in a
moment. She can't effusively praise the speech,
but she's kind of trying to defend it. And the
point here is when even Harris Faulkner is this
lukewarm, you know, that it's not very good.
Speaker 4: And post is a weird day.
Speaker 2: Never thought I'd see it, but here we
are. You know what I pick up on with what you're
saying is right where Trump went from Mar-A-Lago
last night, and that is, you know, he didn't call
it a whiff. I'm going to call it one.
Speaker 1: Oh, he is calling
it. Okay. Interesting.
Speaker 2: Alvin Bragg.
Speaker 1: And did you see how someone's
pointing? That's very, very strange. Someone's
pointing almost like they want the camera only
on Harris Faulkner during this speech. That's
very interesting. Those are those pans that pop.
Speaker 2: All of a whiff. I'm going to call it
one when we see Alvin Bragg there before all
the reporters and they're pressing why now
and what new evidence. And he's dodging and
weaving. And his answers were terrible. They
were terrible. But he kept talking. So I mean,
it was just like it was like nothing is coming
out of his mouth. When you see that Trump
didn't stop there, it didn't pick up there.
Where he went was. But they'll they'll still be
coming for me. So let me tell you what's coming.
Speaker 1: I guess he's saying
the Bragg press conference was
a it's so hard to know what she's talking about.
Speaker 2: Like and I always find it interesting,
and I did last night for somebody to lay out a
case for you of how your enemies are coming to get
you to lay out the other cases, get ready. They're
going to keep coming. And here are the holes in
the next one that telegraphs that he's not so
worried about this one. Not getting too far ahead
of it. They still have to make motions by August.
There's a date in August. And of course, they want
to push this to December 4th, but maybe it won't
ever happen. Maybe we won't ever get to trial or
court or anywhere else with this case. But what we
do know is he's playing, again the role of someone
who wants to solve the problems of the country.
Speaker 1: Okay. So this is this is actually
much more delusional than I thought.
Speaker 2: He talked about that. He
he mentioned the things that Americans
are going through and at the same time,
don't think that they're not going to
come get me again and again and again,
as they always do as they did today, because I'm
trying to save the country. It was interesting.
It was short. He read the prompter.
Speaker 1: He left from a political
messaging standpoint, though. All right.
Well, I guess I mean, I don't know if the
first of all, wasn't reading from a teleprompter
bad. He showed up, he read the prompter,
any left. Trump spent years saying that Obama
reading from a teleprompter was some form of
cheating and dishonesty. And Fox News spent years
agreeing that Obama reading from a teleprompter is
dishonesty. Then Trump used a teleprompter his
entire four years and then used one on Tuesday
night. And now listen, he showed up. He did what
he had to do. He read off of his prompter and he
left. The real point here, though, is the idea
that Trump described to Americans the things that
Americans are going through. Trump talked about
the National Archives, classified documents, hush
money, payoffs, a perfect phone call, Ukraine.
These are the issues that Americans are going
through. That's an extraordinarily who hasn't been
indicted for 34 felonies. Let's all come together
as Americans. So, listen, I think Harris Faulkner
knows it wasn't exactly a titillating performance
that people were expecting Trump with fire. He's
sort of low energy while very sweaty and visibly
confused. Read his speech off the prompter. It was
the standard set of grievances we've been hearing
at every rally, and nobody was particularly
impressed with it. Outside of the Fox News bubble,
One guy who was clearly desperate that night,
seemingly knowing how poorly at what was Trump
himself because he ended up doing something
he doesn't often do, Trump turned to God